[Music]
good evening I'm Laura Walter from the
long now foundation I'm the director of
the Rosetta project
and as some of you may know this summer
we finished our first prototype rows at
a disc after eight years of work and and
so now five copies of that disc are out
there in the world that is the very
long-term archive of the Rosetta project
which is uh as you know is a collection
of the world's languages and when we
made that available and over the past
several years we've had many many
requests for a version that wouldn't
cost $25,000 and and that we could
distribute it very widely so I'm very
pleased to announce that we have now
made a version that can be distributed
very widely and this is a digital fully
browsable version of the disc which is
available now on DVD and today we've
made it available on the Rosetta project
website for anybody to go and interact
with and so this is what it looks like
so now if you go to Rosetta project org
this is what you see and this gives you
the virtual experience of looking at the
Rose at a disk through a microscope
except you were browsing it on your
computer and so what you see here is the
what we call the human eye readable side
so this is the part that starts with
languages at a scale that the human eye
can see
and that tells you this is an archive of
the world's languages and then this the
the text spirals down and gets
progressively smaller and smaller and
inside those radiating spokes our lists
are a list of languages that have
information on the other side of the
disk so I'll show you what this looks
like
you can browse all the way in the
languages are arranged by geographic
region and so you can see I'm zooming in
on the Americas and getting closer
closer and here you can see we have
documentation in the Rosetta project on
the piraha
language that
dan Everett is going to be talking about
tonight so there's more appear aha which
is the very small language grouping that
Peter hot belongs to and you can also
look at the other side of the disc this
is the archive side so this side has
about 14,000 pages of documentation
about 1,500 languages
there's about 7,000 languages in the
world so this is a good chunk of them
and you can also zoom all the way in on
this one so now we're zooming into the
region that has documentation on
languages of the Americas and getting
closer and closer and closer
aha turns out we have information on
Peter hot by Daniel Everett so you're
very welcome to to go browse the site at
your leisure
you can also buy DVD versions of of this
disc so it is now my very great pleasure
to introduce the speaker for tonight Dan
Everett a linguist who's worked for many
many years with an endangered language
the a group of people called the piraha
along the Amazon River and in the 70s as
he's going to tell you much more about
he equipped as a missionary went with
his entire family to work with epi aha
and he had his missionary tools and
beliefs he had his linguistic tools and
beliefs and he went there and what he
learned from this very small group of
people shook actually rocked both of
those sets of beliefs and changed his
worldview in a very fundamental way and
also changed the way that he looked at
language and now his research and his
writings on language are changing the
way all of us think about language works
and how it's encoded in the human mind
let me introduce and welcome Dan Everett
great good to be here this evening have
you ever imagined that you were god
that's something that I think about once
in a while and when I do I think maybe
the Tower of Babel could have been
different than it was the story was
originally told maybe God actually liked
the results of humans creating some
Tower and he decided to take out of this
one language and make many and send
people around the world to solve
problems as it were creating thousands
of other atoms to name and not atom Aton
but atom adam2 create and name other
creatures and learn about the world
around them and languages have spread
around the globe we don't really know
where the first language started but we
have ideas about how long ago it might
have been and we do know that languages
thrive and that the general principle
that makes languages alike or different
is very simple you talk like who you
talk with so if you talk with somebody
all the time you'll talk like them and
if you don't talk with them eventually
you won't talk like them at all so
languages live like bread and love and
by being shared with others but
languages die also and languages die in
one of two ways first way is that the
speakers actually die and so if the
speakers of a language died out the
language is is going to die and the pita
ha almost died out in the early 60s they
got down to 80 or 90 because of a
measles epidemic and event eventually
have come back up to 350 people but
that's still a very small number
another reason languages die die is
because the speaker stops speaking them
the speakers live but they shift to
another language so the languages that
are gone usually won't come back so the
language of Squanto the the Indian
fellow you all remember from your
history books who helped the pilgrims
make it through the first winter the
tupinambá
who occupied the coast of Brazil in the
1500s and were eventually wiped out by a
combination of factors mainly the the
activities of Jesuit priests and another
language that might be dying out is
Irish and and we don't know how much
longer that will last
there are almost 7,000 or more than
7,000 languages spoken in the world and
all the red regions that you see are the
areas of highest concentration of
languages so if you look very carefully
at the world map you'll see that the
highest concentration of languages in
the world
is Papua New Guinea in Brazil there are
about a hundred and eighty-eight
languages still spoken probably half the
number that were spoken in the 1500s and
a population of less than 200,000 people
what's the scale of language loss in the
world what I want to do this evening is
talk to you about the general issues of
language loss and what that means to us
when when languages die but also very
specifically look at a case study the
peat aha people that I've spent the last
30 years working with and and the
lessons that they have for us both
scientifically and how to live lives as
human beings on planet earth there are
six thousand nine hundred and twelve to
seven thousand languages nobody knows
exactly how many but around that number
3,500 languages are spoken by 0.2
percent of the world's population so
almost half the world's languages or
half the world's languages are spoken by
only 0.2% of the population forty
percent of the languages in the world
are endangered some estimates go as high
as one language every two weeks going
becoming extinct that's much higher than
mammals only eighteen percent or five
percent of fish or eight percent of
plants according to a new book that I
highly recommend by David Harrison on
when languages die so what is lost the
late Ken Hale linguist at MIT was one of
the greatest field workers who ever
lived
said that when a single language is lost
it's worse than a bomb dropped on the
Louvre it's a museum it's a repository
of knowledge that can't be replaced it's
not written most of these languages and
written at all linguists have to go
there and develop writing systems that
are not written there's no way to
recover the knowledge once it's gone
once these languages are lost we lose
ways of life and records of ways of life
we lose solutions to problems we lose
classifications of plants and animals
and folk knowledge of the world we lose
myths
folk tales lullaby songs poetry and
literature talk in codes ways of life
one of the groups that I've worked on in
the Amazon are the what II who were
until about 1962 cannibals and they
practice EXO and endo cannibalism EXO
cannibalism eat your enemies endo
cannibalism eat your own dead and the
reason that they ate their dead which
was a very elaborate set of rituals was
to among other things to give the dead
immortality they live on through us as
we eat them and consume our beloved and
the first people to have to consume the
dead we're the immediate family to be
able to give them eternal life through
us the wadi discourse about death and
immortality is fascinating and and
teaches us a lot about how to face death
and how to live lives unafraid of death
in the world and that's going as the
what a language is more and more
endangered almost 50% some people say
fifty five percent of the foods consumed
in the world today come from the
Americas cassava manioc chiles coca
coffee tobacco corn some people have
claimed that corn might be the greatest
invention in human history it does seem
to have been invented by the Mayas or
predecessors to the Mayas from husbandry
of different kinds of grasses and it's
certainly one of the most widely
consumed foods in the world but as these
languages have died the question that
arises for us is what else have we lost
and the answer is we will never know how
many cures for diseases how many other
foods how many other great stories and
philosophies have we lost because these
people have gone we lose information
when these languages died about
classifications and taxonomy z' of the
world so the ymp indians of brazil's
speakers of a tupi guarani language
classify birds
every bird in their environment is
carefully classified but they don't
classify them just like we do so for
example someone noticed a colleague of
mine in Brazil Alan Jensen when he did
his dissertation on them that one type
of hawk is classified in the two cons
why would they classify a hawk among the
two cons surely they can see the
difference the reason is their
classification system follows the foods
they eat and certain kinds of behavior
and this Hawk as we got to know more
about it actually eats what to cleanse
eat and and has a behavior similar to
theirs we lose this kind of knowledge
this folk knowledge that is vital to us
understanding the way the world works
especially in these local environments
when I ask the word for dog in PETA ha I
got two words Neal PI and niai bye and I
asked them why are there two words now
that's the way it is and then I saw them
bring in two jungle animals that
according to my book of mammals in the
tropics were both extinct and they were
called jungle dogs and it said they
haven't been seen in the wild for over
fifty years and here the PETA ha had to
they were keeping his pets in the
village and knew all about their
behavior all about the things they eat
and the places they stay things that
biologists would love to know and we
lose this as these languages begin to
die out we know for example that 2p
Indians in Brazil have heavily
influenced Brazilian literature from the
legends that were written down by
Catholic priests we learn things about
calendars and the way time is kept so
the notches indians of louisiana in the
united states keep their calendar
according to crops that grow at certain
times and and by knowing how their
language works and how they keep time we
learned something about crops and how
different kinds of crops have entered it
the area historically when languages die
it's like to me a great disturbance in
the force there's something about human
humanity and the unity of all humans and
the things that we all depend on the
knowledge that we've been we spread
around the world to share with one
another is is lost so I want to talk to
you first about a small group that I've
worked with called the bona wah and then
I'll spend most of my time talking with
you about the peat aha the bada wah are
now only 79 people
they are members of a family called the
Arawa family and there are only seven
languages left in this family and the
biggest one is about 1,500 people spoken
in Peru and recently was accused of
being cannibals and this is a very
highly charged accusation in South
America because if you can find that a
group is cannibals the idea is they
don't deserve any land or anything it's
completely false that they're cannibals
there's no evidence whatsoever for this
that any group anymore practices
cannibalism not that I would care but
the population of the Bona Y's is 79 as
of 2005 the last time I was there and
one type of special knowledge that the
Bona hua have is how to make poison so
they hunt with long blow guns and poison
darts and these this is really
fascinating technology to know how to
make poison according to ethno botanist
mark Plotkin in his book the shaman's
apprentice is is really to sit at the
top of knowledge about the uses of of
the plants around you and and the
knowledge of how different poisons
affect what kinds of ingredients do you
put in the poison i remember going with
a bona hua man to collect poison one
time and film the entire process and
here he is getting poison it doesn't
look like poison doesn't just look like
a tree but actually it's a vine that
grows up high and in the trees of the
jungly has to climb up cut the vine to
vine Falls
it's full of strychnine in the bark and
so I didn't know that so I walked over
this guy's cutting I just picked it up
and said what's this and he said he
looked at my hands to make sure there
were no cuts in everything he said you
shouldn't have done that wash your hands
as soon as we get back to the village
and don't put them in your eyes or your
mouth on the way back they take
strychnine from the bark and they use
this to make a very potent poison that
goes on darts and and the first sample
of this poison was taken in the 1800's
and taken to the Smithsonian Institution
and a hundred years later they tested
the poison and it was still just as
lethal as when they had originally
collected it so they know how to make
very good poisons and they make blow
guns to hunt with I remember bringing
quite a few of their darts and and
guns to the States for the Carnegie
Museum in Pittsburgh had him in a long
PVC pipe of just I didn't occur to me
that that pipe could break and those
darts could get so don't tell anybody
that I brought this up here but we were
going through customs and the guy said
open the pipe and I tried to open and it
wouldn't open it was hard he said I'll
just go on through and my son who was
about eight then said who we could have
brought cocaine endangered languages in
danger science and the reason for that
is there are many different areas of
science many different Sciences that
want to know where language came from
how does it relate to the evolution of
our species is there anything like it in
other species what is language like
what's the essence of language how does
it relate to the mind how does it relate
to culture what's the connection between
the things we believe and the values
that we share and the way we talk is
there any connection we can't know this
until we get a wide variety of languages
to study so I'm going to talk to you
about people that are called in the
literature the Pete AHA's but who don't
even know what that word means
themselves they call themselves the he
idea and they talk something like this
oh hell I saw high up by Tears so here
hearty ABBA I go which means don't speak
with a crooked head to me speak with a
straight head and their language is
called a straight head and you guessed
what our language is called a crooked
head they call themselves the straight
ones they're found in Brazil if you took
out all of the country boundaries of
South America the pita ha would be right
in the heart of the Amazon jungle right
in the heart of South America as a
confident
these are the kinds of sounds you go to
sleep with at night the pita ha have a
great expression when you go to bed at
night and if that is I thought I saw a
tick I tick
don't sleep there are snakes if they
know you're afraid of something else
though they might say hi hi oh we don't
sleep there are tarantulas they're not
they you know whatever makes you the
most afraid but they say this to
themselves and they don't sleep solidly
all night long
fields research and figuring out these
languages takes a certain amount of time
the reason this photo is in there is the
little boy standing by me is now in his
second year as an assistant professor of
anthropology at the University of Miami
and when I first went to the PETA he was
9 months old
[Music]
now if you notice when one starts
singing the others are about a syllable
behind him and the reason for that is
they haven't sung this song before he's
telling them about an experience that he
had that day and they are just following
along about a syllable behind singing
with him and when you analyze the
singing it turns out that it's nothing
more than their language it's not an
invented melody the tones of their words
and the stress patterns of their words
in the length of their syllables produce
the singing effect and they accent those
things to produce music but it's just
part of their normal speed
that's the spirit speaking the pita ha
only believe and we'll talk about this
in in more detail the pita how believed
and what they can see or what someone
who has seen tells them about so how do
they believe in spirits well they
believe they've seen them they think I
am one still I mean just last year when
I thought we were great friends and
there was no mysteries between us they
one of them said hey Dan what do
Americans died and I said yeah but I
didn't want any research conducted
I said yes we do die and they said well
you know you're really old and you're
not dead yet so I told him about wars
and this sort of thing which was a
fascinating conversation to tell them
that groups of people would go out and
kill other groups of people and I think
there was a German researcher with me at
the time and I talked to them about you
know world war two as best as I could
explain that in in pita ha and they just
found it fascinating that we killed each
other but at least it let them know that
we did die my name when I first went to
the pita how they don't use foreign
names so my first name was oldie I I was
just named after someone else in the
village my next night name was I big I
which just means strong but I don't
think that was really a compliment
and I don't know exactly what they meant
by that but it wasn't a compliment from
the way they used it and then finally I
was in the village camping out it was
late at night and I'd been traveling at
night I was sort of lost on the river
and I found this village and I got my
tent up put my tent up in the in the
middle of the village the fires were
going and I was really tired and one of
the the pita Hawk came said I want to
talk to you and I said I'd really rather
sleep I'm tired
he said just let me talk to you and I
came out and he said your name is I big
guy but you know you really that's not a
good name for you anymore I said why he
says because now you're really old and
so I'm gonna name you after my father
who died and so my name now is pow I see
it's because I'm old this fellow's old
his name is joy boy but as you can see
he's very fit his skin is tough as
leather he's still a very good hunter
and Fisher and you can see how long
their arrows are and how big their bows
are there are fascinating people they're
also interesting because the canoe is
such a vital part of their lives and
they don't make them they prefer to
steal them I taught them how to make
canoes once I brought a Brazilian in who
made canoes and we worked on it together
for days and after we got a great canoe
going the Brazilian left and then they
came in we'd like another canoe like
that I said well I've got the tools you
know how to make it Oh Peter how to make
canoes
why not that's hard work so what do the
pita has have to teach us what does this
small group of 350 people scattered
along the myci River in in the center
center of the Amazon rainforest have to
teach us if anything and and in fact I
think they have a lot to teach us from
the perspective of science they have
things to teach us about the
relationship between language and
culture about the origin of language
about the role and nature of language
whether language is an instinct or a
tool I think they have things to say
about all of these important scientific
topics but as human beings they have
perhaps even more to teach us about
their happiness and their way of life
recently a team of three MIT cyclo
linguists went with me to to check out
some of the claims that I've made that
have been controversial to people and
when we got there after we'd been there
for a few days they both the team said
these seem like the happiest people
we've ever seen well how would you
evaluate happiness as good psychologists
they said we just measure the time they
spend smiling and laughing and compare
that to the time that Americans for
example spend smiling in the laughing
and I bet you there come out ahead the
PETA ha have a very interesting concept
among all Amazonian tribes that as far
as I can tell one important value that
is shared is called a media sea of
experienced Amazonian tribes are very
interested in what's going on now and
they tend not to value so much the deep
past or the distant future but to focus
on now and many anthropologist have
commented on that but I don't know of
any other group that has a concept which
the PETA ha call ebay peel and a BPO is
a fascinating concept when you're out
there they don't speak Portuguese by the
way so when I first went there in
December of 1977 and got off the plane
airsick and looking for the first place
to throw up they started talking to me
and I didn't understand anything they
said so concept like a BPO these kinds
of concepts are really difficult to
figure out when there's no language in
common so I remember once a fellow
walked into the jungle and they said he
a BPO left and then somebody else came
out of the jungle and they said he a BPO
arrived
well maybe it means he just left he just
arrived then I saw someone go around the
bend in a canoe and they said he if
appeal left he came back he bit peel
left Plains they would say EBIT peel and
then one night I find my candles and I
just had a match and my flashlight
batteries were dead and I had this can
of this match lit and it was flickering
and they said the match is a bit peeling
they used it as a verb and I couldn't
figure out what on earth would this mean
well it means to go in and out of the
boundaries of experience if you want to
use a technical term you can say that
refers to experiential liminality but it
simply means to go in and out of
experience this is so important to them
you know not we do this when we're
children
you know peekaboo that's sort of the
equivalent to if appeal and in our
vocabulary it is it is the excitement of
seeing something go in and out of
experience and the pita have codified
that and made it a very important part
of their language and an important part
of their culture and one thing I noticed
was that their verb structure so English
has how many verb forms well it's got
about five seeing saying some singing
sings Spanish or Portuguese might have
40 different verb forms well Pete aha
like many American Indian languages has
a very complex verbal system so Pete AHA
has sixteen different suffixes that can
go at the end of a verb that gives two
to the 16th power possible verb forms
and and that's a lot that's more than 40
and of those things three suffixes are
very important and those tell you how
you got your evidence so every verb has
to have on it the source of the evidence
did you hear about it did you see it
with your own eyes or did you deduce it
from the local evidence so if I say did
John go fishing they can say John went
fishing he I which means I heard that he
did or they can say John went fishing
Sibugay
and that means I deduced that he did or
they can say John went fishing ha and
that means I saw it he went in some
respects
they're the ultimate empiricists or like
people from Missouri the show-me-state
part of this cultural value of the pinna
ha immediacy of experience reflected in
this word if appeal produces a value to
keep information slow and to keep it
verifiable and it must be witnessed so
as a Christian missionary which I no
longer M if you read the book you'll
find out what they did to me
they actually demanded evidence for what
I believed and I realized I couldn't
give it as well as they wanted me to
give it so this changed me profoundly
but I remember telling them about Jesus
one time and they said so then Jesus is
he brown like us or is he white like you
I don't know I haven't seen him well
what did your dad say cuz your dad must
have seen him no he never saw him well
what did your friends say who saw him
well I didn't have nobody I don't know
anybody who saw him why are you telling
us about him then why would you talk
about something you don't have evidence
for of course we do that all the time
Peter ha talk about a fish now I
shouldn't make them sound like Saints
because one of the great functions of
this suffix and say I saw it with my own
eyes is to lie so it worked they do lie
and and I remember once taking a story
about how they killed their babies
infanticide and I took this I was really
getting into this I was taking this
whole story down infanticide and they
all started laughing I said what are you
laughing for who would kill her babies
[Applause]
difficulties of being an anthropologist
than the now one of the interesting
things about peat aha
in fact it's extremely interesting is
that they don't have any numbers they
don't even have the word for one and
they don't have even the concept of
County now it took me a long time to
work up the courage to make this claim
they have a couple of words that might
be like numbers one of them is win which
I originally translated is one and
another one is winged which I translated
as two and then there's another one
bagi so which I translated as mini so
one too many
there are Australian languages that have
one too many systems or other languages
like this but then I realized that if I
had if I had if I had two three fish of
the same size and two of them were in
one pile and one was in another then
they would in fact use the word I
thought meant one for the one fish and
the word I thought meant two for the two
fish but if the fish were different
sizes so that there was one large fish
into very small fish then they used the
word that I thought meant one for the
two very small fish and the word that I
thought meant two for the very large
fish and I began to and then I realized
that that was the same word that was
appearing as a suffix on the noun for
man to refer to a little boy a little
boy baby so it means a little amount but
it doesn't mean a number well when I
made this claim a lot of people didn't
believe me and so psychology
psychologists from MIT came down and we
published a paper in cognition
eventually which last year won the you
know was named by Discover Magazine as
one of the most 100 top science stories
of the year but why would Discover
Magazine what would anybody find that
particularly interesting because it's
been claimed that number is innate to
human beings there are many people who
believe that number is an innate as part
of the innate endowment of human beings
but we all have numbers of some sort if
you show a group that doesn't have any
numbers or any concept of counting what
does that mean
well one thing it does not mean is that
they're [ __ ] it doesn't mean that
they're stupid I've seen PETA who have
been kidnapped and raised outside the
village as Brazilians who handle all the
numbers just
I met a young girl once about 13 years
old behind a counter in a store in a
village of Brazilians not far from the
pita high reservation if you look very
familiar and I was staring at her and a
guy said oh you think she looks like the
pita ha and I said actually I do well
that's because she is a pita how we took
her when she was a little girl
and she kept store and made all the
change and pita had children when when
exposed when we tried to teach them
numbers in portuguese lu learn these
fairly quickly but they do not have in
their language a word for any number now
one of the ways that we showed that was
to get them first - we would put objects
in front of them one at a time and asked
them to name the quantities as we went
up you know what's the size of this so
when we put one spool of thread they
would say when one if we put two spools
of thread they would say Hawaii - and
then once we got up to higher numbers
sometimes by three but certainly by ten
we got boggy so but I had already
figured out that boggy so meant to cause
to touch to pile things up it really
wasn't a number but when we started with
say ten items on the page or ten items
on the board in front of us and and
started taking them away what you find
is that they start with the same so that
the right end of both charts looks
pretty much the same but once you start
getting down to even six some of the
Peter higher you are using the word I
thought meant one way so how on earth
could they call six one and when you get
to three if you're counting down they
all say one what I thought was one and
the reason is the the relative smallness
of that quantity is what's in focus for
them and so they use the word that means
relatively small in the appropriate
context but it's not a number and if
that's not a number what does that mean
what does that mean for the ability to
count so we have a research proposal in
now to go down and look at the Pina ha
from the perspective of of Education one
would be the best time to introduce math
what happens if people haven't had math
for a long time there are a lot of
proposals that have been based on the
idea that all humans have math that it's
innate and that it mature
certain ages but here's a tribe that
doesn't have it at all another thing
about the pita ha I won't have time to
mention all the great things about them
especially there's their sense of humor
I've alluded to it but is they have no
creation stories they don't believe they
don't just demand evidence for my God
the God that I used to have they demand
evidence for any God so they don't have
one they don't believe in God they don't
believe the world was ever created they
just you asked them and you can finally
get the idea across it's hard enough to
get the idea of something they don't
even believe in across they say well
it's just the way it always was this is
the way the world is what do you what do
you mean I said what was the world like
before there was water before there was
water that's a stupid question
and there always has been water there's
always there have always been trees they
have no creation stories they don't
believe in heaven they don't believe in
hell
they take life very much as it comes
they don't want to die but when they see
death is coming they don't fear it they
don't they certainly have sorrow when
the death of a loved one dies or a dog
they love dogs tremendously and so I've
seen women cry all night long and I
thought somebody died and I went over
and I said what's she crying about they
get embarrassed oh I don't know what
she's crying for well but what is she
crying for Oh her dog died and and they
definitely have sorrow about these
things but they they get over very
quickly they realize that the death is
part of life and they don't create any
legends to make themselves feel better
about any myths to make themselves feel
better in the absence of life they have
the simplest kinship system known so
there's a word for me there's a word for
anybody of my generation regardless of
gender there's a word for the generation
above me there's a word for the
generation a below me and then there's a
word from my biological son and/or my
biological daughter and that's it
that's exhaust their kinship system and
if you know much about kinship systems
and marriage rules like we have here you
can't marry your first cousin the more
elaborate the kinship system usually the
more elaborate the marriage rules so the
less elaborate the kinship system so
I've seen half sisters and half brothers
married I've never seen full siblings
married but
there's no difference between brother
and son anyone else of your generation
it just is a huggie one of the things
have frustrated me when I was one of the
many things when I was starting to work
with a PETA howl was trying to find the
words for left and right so I would say
this is my left hand so I would say in
Portuguese which means nothing to them
cuz they don't speak Portuguese but I
had to say something mom we scared them
and they would say okay hand okay that's
my right hand hand that's your other
hand so after a while you know I
couldn't get this and I thought I must
be a terrible English I can't even get
left hand or right hand and then one of
them said you know that hands up river
in this hand is downriver and I said you
know what are they introducing this
irrelevant stuff I'm trying to get left
hand or right hand here and so we went
out to the jungle and I said okay now
I'll find it they'll tell this guy to
turn left or turn right so so they said
hey turn up River we're in the middle of
the jungle and he turns up river and
they said turn down River turn towards
the center of the jungle turn towards
the water I realized that and this turns
out not to be unique to the peat AHA
many other groups have this they use
systems of absolute direction it's as
though we only use north south east and
west rather than left or right and we
know that left or right are really not
the best way to give directions because
if I stand up here and tell you to turn
left and use my left that you're right
but if I tell you to turn upriver
where's the closest river well if you
were a pita high you would know that
if you were a PETA ha you would have a
map of your local environment in your
head when I walk with the PETA house in
the jungle and I asked them what's this
tree
they give me a name and I write it down
what's this tree they're always
different they know the name of every
species so they ask me what do you call
these in your language what's that tree
what's that tree you just have one word
that's all I know but there's some
people that know more but I don't the
PETA ha don't even have words for
yesterday or tomorrow and I found this
very strange as a word for other day
there's a word for now there's a word
for Big Time a word for a little time
but they don't have and there's a word
for a son as big meaning noon or the
moon is big meaning full moon but they
don't have yesterday or tomorrow for
example why wouldn't they have that well
one of the interesting discoveries about
the piraha
is that their time their view of time is
that it's concentric you take the moment
of speech and it's things are a certain
distance from that if they're close by
they use one word which means literally
other day if they're a little bit
farther away they use another word big
time which could be future or past
so they conceive of time differently
than we do at least in this superficial
way I mean I haven't done detailed
studies to get the peterhof philosophy
of time and they would probably tell me
to go find something else to do but it's
something to think about in any case the
concentric circle view of time as
opposed to the linear view of time is is
a new way to conceive of time and and
comparing how different cultures talk
about even something as much a part of
our daily experience as time can open up
new vistas now you have to be probably a
linguist to appreciate this but I'll try
to give you some of the excitement about
it
so one of the greatest sources of hate
mail that I've ever had is the claim
that the pita ha language lacks
recursion that there's their grammar
lacks recursion now what is recursion
and who cares anyway so let me tell you
what it is and then why it's important
and why the pita are important for the
study of it recursion is any rule or any
opera
raishin that applies to itself that
sounds simple right so so take the act
of looking at yourself in a mirror or
looking at a reflection now if you if
you just look at yourself in the mirror
that's one exemplar of reflection but if
you hold a mirror up to another mirror
what do you get you get one mirror
inside another mirror inside another
mirror inside another mirror that's
recursive whatever it is it's the
recursion of visual images reappearing
now I used to play in bands in fact my
first experience with San Francisco was
when I was growing up in Imperial Valley
California I got arrested trying to come
up here in the 60s trying to get to
Haight Ashbury I was only 15 and my dad
didn't like the idea that I was coming
up here to live because I played in
bands and one of the of course like
everybody in the 60s admired the
innovation of Jimi Hendrix and one of
the most amazing things that he did was
to really take advantage of auditory
recursion called feedback holding up a
guitar and letting an amplifier pick up
its own output and do it apply to its
own output over and over again now that
makes the different definition of
recursion and it produces feedback which
to some people can sound like noise but
in the hands of Jimi Hendrix was
beautiful music now in a recent paper in
2002 Noam Chomsky and mark Hauser
biologists at Harvard University Noam
Chomsky's a linguist at MIT also known
for other writings and to come to Fitch
who's a biologist at the st. Andrews
University in Scotland proposed that the
fundamental property of human language
in the sense that it is the only unique
part of the only unique characteristic
that language is built on that
distinguishes us from other species is
recursion so how does this work in
language and why do they think it's
important well think of a sentence like
the boy was fishing
that's one sentence but I've what if I
take whatever rule made that sentence
and apply it to itself then I can say
the boy who was fishing owned the dog so
I have a sentence inside a sentence or
the dog the boy who was fishing owned
the farmer or the farmer the dog the boy
who was fishing owned bit got the gun at
some point lose track of one of my
favorite examples as oysters oysters eat
eat oysters so that's actually a
grammatical sentence but I it's really
hard to understand I'll let you think
about it
recursion is supposed to be very
important so you get it in words truck
driver it's a truck inside drive and you
get this other word truck driver it was
a kick the bucket moment whatever that
means but kick the bucket is a series of
words used inside another word and this
is recursion human languages what's the
longest sentence in English who knows
the idea is that it might be infinite
and the only way we can do that with
brains the size of grapefruits is to
have some device that allows us to
produce sentences that get that big
without actually having to memorize the
sentences so that's supposed to be the
role of recursion so they claimed this
was unique to humans this is the they
don't like it when I characterize it
this way but I think it's right so I'll
just say it anyway
the essence of human language recursion
now it turns out that Peter ha doesn't
have that and I don't think it's the
only language like that but how would
you say I want the hammock that bill
sold
okay that's recursion that's the
sentence inside another sentence how
would you say that Peter hi you say I
want the sentence I want the sentence we
could say that too perhaps
I went to hammock bill sold the hammock
and then I interpret that together in
various ways and one of the ways is I
want the hammock bill sold the reason
this is important is because if the
piraha
don't have recursion my explanation is
first of all it's important if they
don't have recursion whatever the
explanation is because if you claim that
it's the essence of human language and
you don't find it in a human language
that's a problem now some people have
said well this just like finding a in
fact Chomsky said this about me recently
in it in a newspaper interview he says
well let's say that Peter ha is just the
way Dan didn't say Dan actually says
something else but he says this person
describes it and that
this is more or less equivalent to the
idea of finding a group of people that
just crawls when they could walk what
does that have to tell us about human
biology nothing okay
well that's a difficult position to hold
because if the language could be as I
said it was and he admits that it could
be then it's possible for that language
not to be like it was predicted to be
and it's also possible for a third of
the languages in the world not to be
that way
ultimately it's possible that no
language has it and if no language has
it then no language can support or
refute the idea
so some philosophers if an idea can't be
supported or refuted it's not a
particularly useful idea so maybe it's
wrong and if that if that idea is wrong
then it means that language is different
than it was proposed by these three
eminent researchers and if it is
different what might it be it might
simply be the result of a number of
kinds of constraints on how it is we
talk to each other controlled by
cultural values and if cultural values
can can affect language then this means
that language probably is not the innate
instinct that say Steven Pinker and
others say that it is and this leads to
fascinating research so a lot of people
are testing what I'm saying there's a
lot of discussion of this and and I do
get a lot of hate mail as a result of
saying that PETA ha don't have recursion
but that's all right I can take it
culture is very important by learning
the ways that language combined with
culture we learn lessons about the
environment so I remember going with the
pita ha upriver one time and I saw some
bubbles in the water and I said what's
that and I wanted to get the word for
bubbles but they didn't tell me the word
for bubbles they told me the word for a
species of fish those that's not a fish
that's a bubble so I tried to get it
across them they said no it's that
species of fish they do they eat this
kind of thing down below the water and
it reduces it releases bubbles who would
have known that there very few people
would have known that if they didn't
grow up around those around those fish
and know those fish walking in the
jungle see a branch Swain now to me I
don't know if the branch is Swain
because of
of wind that's usually what I figure it
is although the Pina Homme will point
out to me that no other branch is
swaying and if it were when maybe the
other branches would be swinging and it
turns out to be a certain species of
monkey and they know that it inhabits
that kind of tree and that it has this
kind of behavior and it operates at this
time of day not at night I've been
walking with them many times and they
tell me to stop because I'm about to
step on a snake or you see that I
remember going hunting with him one time
and and we had gone out a couple of
miles from the village and they said hey
Dan what you're making a lot of noise
well I just trying to you know I had my
canteen and my machete and and they just
were barefoot with and they said you
just stay here and we'll come back and
get you when we're done so I stood there
by the tree for probably four hours
hoping that there were no Jaguars in the
area assuming that they wouldn't have
left me if there were not knowing that
they would have expected me to be able
to take care of myself because no idiot
would go out into the jungle without
knowing how to take care of themselves
learning about their relationship to the
environment and their knowledge of those
animals animals that many people I don't
know I think I've eaten three species of
extinct mammals in the Phaedo ha and I
didn't make them go extinct they were
just claimed to be extinct in the peat
aha not only know that they're not
extinct they know all about them these
are the kinds of things that we lose and
since the languages aren't written you
can't find this knowledge on the
internet what is lost when we lose a
language we lose everything that one
society has ever thought enough of to
encode in their language there's no
chance to recover from it except of a
bit of the form so one of the few
examples of a language that has been
revived is Hebrew but we know that the
Hebrew that's spoken in Israel today is
not the Hebrew that was spoken 2,000
years ago and there's a lot of
information now that's been encoded
since its native it has a native
speakers again but it's not the same
information that was encoded before it
was lost fortunately Hebrew was written
so one of the legacies is religion and
we we certainly know what that was
because it was written we
lose all the work of 10,000 atoms of the
10,000 naming societies that have gone
out and learned and mastered their
environment and and have all these
things to teach us this is not knowledge
that will ever be available on the
internet this is knowledge that will be
lost forever unless we do something
about it what can we do well one other
thing I want to say before I get to some
suggestions is what is so important
there's a fancy sociological term called
Altera T which just means other nests
getting to know people who are different
recently the BBC asked me to come up
with a 60 second idea to change the
world so in 60 seconds I came up with my
60 second I didn't think it very
seriously but people got really liked
the idea because it was something that
did affect me which is that everyone
should live a week with strangers
everyone should live a week with people
that are very unlike them in many ways
this concept of other nests has been
very profound in my life coming from a
small farming community in Holtville
California and and winding up in in the
middle of the Amazon there's something
that is unappealing about everything
being homogeneous around us about never
experiencing different foods different
ways of life different points of view
these can be threatening but when we the
more that we lose in terms of diversity
of world's languages and cultures the
more opportunities to solve problems the
more different perspectives we lose that
we can never recover the full range of
the etic and the comfort of the emic let
me just tell you those two words these
are really nice words the etic means to
have a perspective of a culture from
someone who's outside the culture just
looking at what they do just random
behaviors it looks like to us but if
you're inside the culture you interpret
these things very differently
that's the emic perspective the
perspective of the insider and the more
we get to know cultures through
individual friends or through travels
through experiences of living abroad the
more we adopt other people's emic
perspective other people's insider
perspective on cultures and as these
cultures and languages disappear people
like the pita ha
we lose this perspective my entire view
of God and religion was altered forever
my entire view of language was altered
forever by the pita ha and it's not
because I've gone native because frankly
I'd prefer to be in San Francisco than
in the Amazon many times I mean I do
enjoy the Amazon but I take a lot of
reading material for the for the nights
and and I'm a terrible hunter I'm you
know people think well you must be you
must be this great outdoorsman no I can
take all this stuff but I'm no good at
it and I don't particularly enjoy it a
lot but it is the experience that has
changed me dramatically not because I've
gone native but because I have seen
profound examples of people who live
differently think differently and have
achieved more success in many respects
than I have in in their lives so what do
we do we can't just watch indifferently
as languages disappear there's a partial
solution one we need to help these
people get land rights we need to help
their state of health try to get the
governments of the world to provide
better health care for these people so
that they don't lose their language
because they all die the second partial
solution is to document and describe
these languages we need more field
researchers the problem is you can't be
what some Australian Ling was called
fifo linguists fly-in fly-out
you can't figure out these languages in
a weekend's worth of study it takes a
long time it takes a long time to figure
out one of these languages even
reasonably well a number another
possible solution is to give one of the
one of the organization's is called the
foundation for endangered languages and
here's its website but there are lots of
other organizations that are interested
in this but documenting endangered
languages is not just butterfly
collecting it is teaching us things and
preserving knowledge that we will never
ever have a chance to preserve again and
then in the mean time those of us who
aren't going to be involved directly in
this read and learn about other cultures
and about these other peoples thank you
[Applause]
thank you Dan
sounds like Noam Chomsky is not
persuaded yet are other people who have
formally been persuaded by Chomsky about
the essentialness of recursiveness now
being persuaded by your experience
they're taking it more seriously the
major journal of linguistics language is
dedicating about half of its June issue
to this discussion is it turning up in
any other tribes or languages yes there
are some others in which people are
starting to re-examine the evidence and
think well maybe I was too hasty and
saying it did have recursion after all
that's what my thesis adviser said but
maybe maybe that's not the way it was
here's a question from Rolf looks like
wooden felt oh yeah
somewhere out here have you ever been
tempted to bring someone from the piraha
tribe back out of there to the world out
there was that thirteen year old girl
you ran into today right yes I've taken
pita ha out of the village to Brazilian
cities for medical work and it's it is
quite interesting to take them out they
take it all in stride they're better
anthropologists than I am they watch and
they behave like the people around them
then good Terrace
is there any in your view now universal
property of language that's not
recursion what do you got the social
need to communicate would be the one
single Universal of language in my
opinion now I gather you're drawing your
dissent saying culture comes first and
language comes from that is that I'm
saying that they emerged together
symbiosis and you can't say that one is
prior to the other but that that you
learn to talk about things you believe
in and you believe in things you talk
about they reinforce one another as they
emerge axel says to the piraha use the
verb to be if so how often
do they use metaphors metaphors sound
recursively maybe they have metaphors
once in a while so to go fast is too
hit the ground with a Bigfoot and they
have the verb to be so for something to
be temporarily like estar and Spanish is
agha
and for something to be as an inherent
quality as ser in Spanish is Agha was
just a tonal difference how do you we
were with you at the airport throwing up
in 1977 these guys come up to you and
start carrying on and that you don't
have you know Portuguese and they don't
how do you learn a language from total
scratch like that started off with
picking up a stick and I pointed to it
and I said stick which but they said oh
yeah
now it could mean all sorts of different
but I bet it meant stick so then I took
stick and I let it fall and and I said
stick falls to the ground they said he
make it collie and I said I wrote down
this probably means stick falls to the
ground and from there we went lots of
false starts and lots of mistakes and I
learned that if they start ribbing each
other in grinning when I'm talking
probably didn't learn it right now you
were there with very young children and
typically kids pick up language pretty
quickly did that happen to your family
yes when we went there my son was nine
months old my middle daughter was three
and my oldest daughter was five and they
they started learning the language much
better than I did much faster than I did
and they would go off with the pita hot
children and spend their entire day
playing were they learning it from other
children permanently yes so my middle
daughter for example since tapes to the
pita home with me but she still sounds
like a little girl because she left so
long are there different forms of the
language for males and females yes the
men have eleven sounds eleven phonemes
three vowels eight consonants the women
have three vowels seven consonants and
and the way they pronounce words is
quite a bit different from them in which
I think they've heard while you're
talking before the during the day the
men are off doing something with other
men and women are off doing something
with other women it's very common to
that the women very often go and collect
fruits and things while the men go off
and and fish and hunt and like in most
societies the women are usually the only
ones who find anything to eat but they
often go off as families as well and do
things as families you mentioned they're
humorous a whole lot of how humor works
is in language so do they do puns I have
never heard a peanut hot pun but I have
they do like to joke about things that
happen and so they spend a lot of time
laughing it's a fairly low sort of
slapstick humor exactly like mine so we
get along very well is there any of the
humor that is in the language I mean
they could tell you a story about
killing babies and that's a I mean lots
of anthropology informants but the clue
isn't presumably in the language of them
telling the story the clue is in that
and the why it's funny to them is it's
an absurd story they're told that's
right that's right they told the story
beautifully so I told the story back to
them I found a cartoon of a dog hunting
and they can't read two-dimensional
objects very well so drawings and
because they're not exposed to them so
drawings and pictures look the same so I
showed them a dog hunting with a gun and
they said where does I didn't told him a
whole story about dogs that hunt with
guns and and they were fascinated and I
said dogs don't hunt with guns so I they
realized that I had gotten them back for
the story about the baby
[Laughter]
yes politely or were they really amused
well they first they were upset they
said you you lied to us I said yes and
you lied to me and we are laughing in it
so it goes
you were telling Kevin Kelly a while ago
that basically they work about four
hours a day right and they don't have
television so what's going on the rest
of the time sit around talking of
gossiping and talking about what they're
gonna do tomorrow and just wasting time
like most of us would like to do if we
had the time to waste
gossiping with only this limited level
of generation and family must be I mean
do they get any on the mother-in-law
weirdness and stuff like that no they
talk about who's a bad hunter and and
who is who's going to go where tomorrow
and what are you gonna do tomorrow and
then they tell lots of sexual jokes
about each other's wives and things so
they I mean English people love to for
some reason and analyze each other's
personalities a lot so two teenagers and
does that go on or people sort of very
alert to each other's characters and
personalities and the difference and
that becomes part of the bye plate yes
they definitely understand they they
have an idea about how every member of
their society works and functions and
they really have knowledge about all the
people in their society but there's not
a great distinction between adults
teenagers and children because everyone
in a harsh environment has to take
responsibility for themselves very early
so you know if you're a rebellious
teenager and you don't want to do
anything that they fine you just won't
eat and so as long as you're willing to
pay the consequences for your own action
nobody's going to tell you what to do
that's actually an important PETA high
value is not telling other people what
to do bring it on
what
are the rituals of you know puberty or
of marriage or coming apart or things go
on around death
no there aren't any rituals except for a
dance that they do when the full moon
and it's debatable whether you would
want to call that a ritual or not and it
gets into technical anthropological
discussion but for example to get
married to people go off and live with
one another and I've seen eight-year-old
children go off and live with each other
for a while because the guy already
knows how to fish and she knows how to
clean fish so they pretend to be then
they go back to their parents but it's
at some point they stay with each other
but there's no particular ritual for
that or puberty or or any typical rite
of passage from Luigi if there's no past
or future can there be spoken
consequences rewards punishments
outcomes how does learning occur in this
sort of timeless frame they do have a
knowledge of past and future and they do
think about the past and future but not
the past that hasn't been experienced
the past in their own lives the past
they have seen and of course we've seen
the entire history of our lives and they
can think about they can think about
anything they want to think about but
they talk about only the immediate
future so you can talk about what
somebody did yesterday and why that has
consequences today that's not a problem
and why you ought not to do this
tomorrow but you won't say something
like you know by in fifty years from now
the Brazilians would have taken over
this part of the jungle
Kyle Elliot has a question what is the
piraha concept of love do they have one
since it cannot be seen they can see the
effects of it they see the effects of
being with someone and so they
definitely are very affectionate with
one another and they use a verb for love
which is is like Spanish and other
languages is to want someone very much
is is to love them and I remember one of
the most moving experiences I had I was
getting ready to leave the village and
the pita ha man who's if anyone seen the
picture of me when my head coming up out
of the river and this guy in the canoe
that guy said to me when I was leaving
he said we really want you I really
love you and and I thought that was
really great I was really moved by that
and he said nobody else gives us coffee
[Laughter]
so you're from outside do they have
contact with other tribes occasionally
there's there's a group of two P
speaking people that are within a two
day walk of the pto village and
sometimes each group walks a day away
from the village to hunt so they do
encounter each other in the jungle and
the peat aha think of them as these
kinds of jungle entities I mean they
know that they speak another language
they know where their villages are but
they don't like them and they're afraid
of them and the pattern change change
this other people for different reasons
are afraid of the peat aha
who do they steal the canoes from
Brazilian river boats that are in that
go by neighboring rivers to look for
Brazil nuts the Pina ha paddle up at
night and take as many canoes as they
can off the ends of the boats and I
guess nobody had any knowledge of what
they used to do before the river boats
were there so it's amiss they make a
bark canoe called caca Hawaii which they
just take the bark off a certain kind of
tree and they put mud at both ends and
that's a canoe and but that doesn't
carry much weight and it doesn't last
very long most of their culture is
disposable they make a basket and they
throw it away as soon as they're done
carrying things and make it very crudely
and just throw it away the only
permanent tools that they there are very
few permanent tools and the most obvious
one is the bow and arrow
how primitive is that it will last a
good bow will last for years and and the
bowstring and the arrow these are the
most elaborate cultural artifacts they
create and presumably there's a lot of
maintenance with those keeping the arrow
straight and things like that yeah you
have to put them in the fire and
straighten the mouth and and make sure
the feathers are twisted right so that
they'll twirl right in the air and and
there's a hole holes science to that and
but every child learns it from their
parents so they see it happen it's not
illiterate there's no literature oral
literature about this is how you make a
bow and arrow this is the kinds of
things you don't need to talk about it's
like telling someone have a literature
about how to get
lots of water so you told several
stories about their intense
observational and certain knowledge
qualities they're embedded in the
language and even more on their
behaviors so they know you know that
there's a shaking tree they know what
kind of treat it is what kind of monkey
it is and probably if they could shoot
it with an arrow a lot of stuff like
that or they more observa t'v in that
sense than other tribal groups or that
just the way it is when you're that
close other tribal groups that have
limited contact with the outside tend to
be roughly comparable I've worked with
over 20 different groups in the Amazon
the groups that are learning Portuguese
and moving away from their language lose
skills with that they lose some of that
knowledge so that I actually recorded
the bond awha that I talked about
briefly imitating animal sounds and I
took that to the pita ha and played it
for them and they all laughed they
recognized every animal and they said
these guys know their animals and I
recorded the PETA han took them to the
Bono and they all recognized them but
the Bono ah are losing their language
and so it's only the older men who can
make those sounds like the pita ha any
PETA ha can make those sounds and who
know all about the animals and their
behavior now one of the remarkable
things you did with the sound here was
we were hearing what sounded like
singing and sort of blending into
speaking and you're saying they're
basically the same
I'm sorry more about that they they can
the pita ha don't even though they only
have three vowels and eight consonants
often speak without using them at all
because they can whistle their language
they can hum their language so if you
see for example a mother and a child
most of the time she won't be talking to
that child with consonants and vowels
she'll be saying things like and just
humming but that's a they can carry on a
full conversation doing that because of
all the rich information that's in the
tones in the length of the words in the
divisions of the words that are even
made in the the syllables made with the
hum speech or the whistle speech or the
yell speech there are various different
kinds of communication that they use
that are unavailable to
to to us in English for because we don't
have tones language even now we can use
it to some degree another fascinating
thing about the pieter hoff whistle
speech is that only men whistle women
don't whistle and if you look at
whistles around the world in almost
every society that has whistle speech
and there are several only men whistle
and even in English up until a few years
ago if anybody was going to do whistling
at another person it tended to be men so
why that is nobody really knows that's
probably profound
okay here's a good Rosetta type question
you mentioned nearly 7,000 documented
languages out there how many of those
are written how many can we put on the
disk oh the ones that are written are
probably around 3,000 probably yes and
again it's very difficult to say because
to even get an idea of these things
writing is a is a very significant
invention in human history it's only
been invented about four or five times
in the history of is less than
agriculture that's amazing and and so it
was invented in the Americas by Sequoia
the Cherokee chief and that's an amazing
accomplishment it was invented by the
Phoenicians it was invented by the
Chinese but it's been invented very few
times so most languages unless someone's
gone there a linguist and used the
international phonetic alphabet to begin
to develop a writing system for them the
language is not written so more than
half the languages of the world are not
written now one of the big things of
missionary endeavor all over the world
as near as I can tell is often to go
into a unwritten language group and then
for the missionaries to start creating a
written form what happens when that goes
on they when they write the language and
the people begin to learn to read and
write it then you see the language
change in several ways because some of
the the oral style is lost because they
start to use the written style begins to
take more of an influence the sentences
often become longer because you write
them down and you can remember them
longer it affects a lot of things we
tried to teach the pita ha how to read
and write at first and after several
weeks of trying they read the word McGee
and they all started laughing and I said
why are you laughing and they said that
sounds just like our word for ground and
I said it is your word for ground and
they said no it isn't we don't write our
language Aysen and so then they stopped
coming to the classes question forum
stewart robinson how do you distinguish
between the lack of a word and the lack
of a concept that's a that's a profound
question and it's a very difficult
question to determine but you can you
can
get at the absence of a concept in in
various ways do they talk about this
thing roundabout in their stories can
you do psychological experiments to see
if they have this concept it's not
transparent it's not a very easy thing
to do but there are ways at getting at
whether they have a word whether they
have a concept but lack the word what do
you tell from lists or storm eyes from
all this about language is being born or
language is being born now or is it just
purely a tale of loss there are always
languages coming into being from nothing
or sort of forking off as dialects and
then become languages well the one type
of language that comes pretty much from
nothing is the creole language and we
find these Creole languages arising in
different parts of the world and those
are fascinating in themselves they've
been taken as some of the greatest
evidence for the language instinct I
don't think they are but it's a long
story but you do also find languages
coming into being when people stop
talking with one another so you find the
greatest divisions of languages where
there are the greatest geographical
obstacles and where people who used to
speak the same language and no longer
speak to one another on a regular basis
their languages change and they become
mutually unintelligible languages well I
wonder about that because Papua New
Guinea that sort of makes sense
chopped-up landscape but here in
california with this big valley in its
coastal connection and so on we had what
26 26 or so language groups is that
right actually they're more even today
they're almost 55 languages spoken in
California okay what's going on well
those languages are now dying out but at
the time one of the highest
concentrations of languages in the world
used to be and still is to a large
extent the northwestern United States
southwestern Canada so Northern
California Oregon Washington up to
British Columbia is a very high
concentration of diverse indigenous
languages and and so there are various
reasons people don't talk to one another
they don't talk to one another sometimes
because of geography but they may not
talk to one another because of tribal
boundaries they may not talk to one
another because of religious beliefs
they may not talk to one another
whatever the reason
are that people stop talking to one
another that failure to communicate will
eventually lead over generations to
separate languages that's something I
saw in East Africa when I was there as
10-year olds who had mastered six or
seven languages three of them European
you know English French German and and
all of the nearby tribal languages and
of course Swahili is this sort of unique
situation of post-colonial connectivity
or normal in the world it's fairly
normal in the world for people who have
to use languages various languages to
master them and it turns out that the
human brain is sufficiently plastic that
when we need to learn other languages we
can it becomes harder when our needs are
less but you often find people who are
polyglots in various parts of the world
whether it's in Africa or Holland so I'm
thinking also I mean part of the I have
very limited knowledge of California
drives but some and and things like hand
game over where it very widely played
among many different tribes and often
between tribes I've seen hand game
played between Paiutes I do completely
different forms of playing the game one
tribe really one even though it's
supposedly a game of chance and we find
artifacts so that most of the Obsidian
the people who are using for arrowheads
and so on came from Mono Lake and had to
go from one place to another in order to
get all the tribes that needed
arrowheads and yet these language
divisions persist so what moves across
then and does it take bilingual people
to do that or is it sign language or
what very often languages represent
cultural values as well and people have
theories or beliefs whatever you want to
call them about how their languages
reflect who they are and they may not
want to learn another language even if
people that they have to come into
contact with so either there could be
someone special designated to learn the
language and represent the tribe they
could use a sign language as the sign
language of the American Indians of the
plains there there are lots of different
ways to get around this issue and in
globalization we're regularly dealing
with people that the average American
doesn't speak Japanese but we have a lot
of contact in trade with the Japanese
with some I mean some tribes steel women
from other tribes and do they presumably
get some bilingual bilingual
capabilities with that yes that's very
common fact there's a part of northern
Brazil which practices something called
linguistic exogamy they have to marry a
woman who speaks a different language
and so there are various people in the
area so what you find is that the
children grow up speaking the mother's
tongue and then if they're a boy they
they switch to their father's tongue
when they when they get past puberty but
this kind of linguistic complication is
is common in that particular situation
is not common but but linguistic
intermarriage is common is that also
happening with the piraha where the the
children are basically speaking the
woman's language until they get to a
certain age and are going off for the
men hunting or yes transition that
happens I mean you find boys in fact
because of all the hum speech that takes
place hmm they tend to use a sound like
a glottal stop if you hear a glottal
stop is a sound that's that's you find
it in English but we don't use it very
importantly so that's a glottal stop
that breaks up the flow of air discussed
issues yes but you find that the the
piraha children will often instead of
saying alligator or or let's see head op
op I very very often they will say I
children especially do that you see use
glottal stops because they haven't
really learned the consonants that well
yet because of hum speech with their
mothers so that we're talking about the
same language one question from Carmen
Olson is do the para have a sign
language and if there is deafness how do
they deal with it there's no sign
language they gesture presumably yeah
they use gestures gestures are very
important in all human cultures and they
reveal a lot about the mind in fact you
can't really study a language without
looking at gestures as well because
that's a very important part of the
communication system there are no deaf
Pete AHA that I'm aware of any time
there are handicapped people they take
good care of them in another tribe of
Brazil the the auto boo Kippur there's a
high incidence of deafness and they have
learned sign language and if there's one
deaf person present in the entire
village
everyone only uses sign language until
that person is gone then they switch to
speaking
yeah I've run into versions of that with
American Indians people teaching
American in completely American Indian
classes often have a problem that nobody
is allowed to Excel and so that they
stay at the level of the you know least
interested student and so that can be a
serious problem in terms of people
connecting with the world
Mike Finney you gave an example numbers
of the concept the piraha can't
understand are the things they can't
understand because they can't use
recursion I haven't found anything but
if you don't talk about I mean actually
recursion is something that people have
made a big deal of but there's nothing
you can say with recursion that you
can't say without it so some people have
told me well how do they have if you say
John said that builds a bad boy bills a
bad boy as a sentence within the
sentence John said that you can't talk
about things that people said without
recursion in fact you can think about
this sentence I threw up that's what
John said anyway those are two separate
sentences and that doesn't involve
recursion and and you can communicate
these things just fine without and they
use workarounds like that yes yeah and
and in fact it just means that the
context plays a much greater role
recursion turns out to be a very useful
device for manipulating the flow of
information when in in cultures where
we're talking about things that not
everyone knows but in a culture Society
of intimates in which everybody pretty
much knows what everybody else is going
to talk about in terms of the topics
they don't need that kind of information
management tool they can have sentences
uttered side by side and there's a lot
of contextual information and cultural
information to get exactly the right
interpretation every time so that totals
shared immersion gives these kinds of
capabilities and it also it sounds like
would lead to absolute directions so
toward the ocean and away from the ocean
right rather than the stage left and
stage right actually the same thing we
just did it
the shared miss what allows what I miss
hearing is that a very intimate group
can have this kind of rather to us
limited language but it only works in a
limited situation like that and and so
the thirteen-year-old piraha girl who
was out and works in a shop she's going
to take on numbers she's got the skill
and in order to get the job she needed
this Gil so it's a moving out from that
intimacy then leads into these other
things that language like numbers and
recursion is on that's right and it's
predicted independently by a lot of
linguistic research done and recently
some people call it esoteric
communication you're talking about
always the same kinds of topics others
refer to it as the Society of intimates
but this has a lot to do with new views
this is quite related to new views on
the evolution of language coming out of
these narrow groups these small groups
into larger groups so human intelligence
didn't change but the complexity of
language changes complexion the
complexity of the syntax the grammar
because of the wider society and the
greater range of experiences and the
information had to be managed
differently so as you go from a very
small hunter-gatherer group to a larger
sort of chieftainship or something like
that to a federation you're gonna have
that reflected in the language you could
there's the the the thing is it's not
required you could have very small
groups with very complex language and
large groups with simple languages but
the general tendency is for the
complexity of the grammar to - to fit
the society in which it's found there's
a lot more research that has to be done
on these things but the one thing we
have to be careful of is not to assume
that if it's a small group they have a
very simple grammar and if it's a large
group they were very complicated grammar
because they we can they can be just the
opposite this relates to a question from
Kevin Kelly Kenna language like parihar
continued outside the environment that
is if I mean lots of diasporas maintain
their language and
using it over the internet and on their
cell phones and so on do you think
piraha if there were a a an exodus would
they maintain the language as it is well
you maintain the form of the language
you maintain the meaning of most of the
words but you begin to lose that
connection with the culture and the
local environment that gives the
language to speak metaphorically it's
sold it really gives the language the
special content that makes it unusual so
so I've told a lot of linguists think
they can do field work in Los Angeles
for example on just about any language
in the world
so you find linguists that apply for
assistant professorship that list field
work on their on their Vita because they
they work with some speakers in Los
Angeles so if I'm right you have to do
field work in the local community where
the culture will still practice you can
look at these other languages there are
other things you can find outside the
cultural community but if you really
want to write a grammar in a dictionary
and figure out how this language works
you need it to be connected to the local
community where the cultures is still
vibrant so I guess I'm starting to get a
question in my mind about second
languages and trade languages like
Swahili like Latin for a while like
French for a while like English now
which is sort of the global language of
science entertainment and various other
things does having a shared second
language help preserve primary languages
or does it erode them it it really
depends on the local values in other
words you can learn another language and
the children can begin to shift away to
that language very quickly
it depends in globalization often
depends on what the economic rewards are
or the or any other kind of rewards are
for continuing to speak your language in
most cases the economic rewards are
speaking the second language began to
overwhelm all the values that reward
speaking the first language so you see
language shift in dramatic numbers it
sounds like with the piraha there are
almost no economic events going on
they're not interested in goods from the
outside world there I've been with so
many Amazonian groups for example who
are like if you offer a really good
knife they're not interested oh they'll
take it they're curious about it they'll
take it they'll use it but they don't
protect it they don't save it I mean you
my
find it laying out in the grass a couple
of days later they have a few tools but
they're not worried about them they're
just not there's a value for the pita ha
is to keep yourself simple to not you
take any not acquire any more than you
can walk off with and very quickly to
not consume more than you need is this
because they see or experience the
failure to do that it's just a value not
to they want to be mobile I mean they
have a nomadic mindset they travel
around a lot they want the whole village
travels or individuals individuals and
families travel and and they they want
to be mobile and they want to be what
they call hard jiggy sigh and to be hard
means to not to be in control of your
body and to not eat too much to not
sleep too much to to hard bodies yeah
hard bodies the straight ones does that
suggest a concept of crooked ones serve
them yes we are crooked ones we are
correct yeah all of us are bent away
which is any kind of thing that's bent
so in the sense that are they saying to
you well we're not used at what straight
ones means or who are they saying
straight ones - they're better better
ones chosen there's right and worth
their language is to speak with a
straight head and and to speak any other
language is to speak with a crooked head
that's it what do you think they're
referring to with crookedness there's
that wood protrusion is and no it's just
it's just unattractive ugly I mean I've
taken them I've taken pita home with me
to visit other Indian villages when I
had to go there for a couple of hours to
for a medical reason or something like
that and I had a PITA how was with me
independently and and I said what did
you think about them they're ugly what
about their water their water stinks
they really have a very high opinion as
I said why do you think I'm here this is
the best place in the world they don't
say the best place in the world but they
say this is a very very good place they
don't have a concept of world they have
a concept of luck in that you were a
lucky person to be there are their luck
and bad luck and bad medicine and they
don't talk about luck somebody told me
about the pita ha
as far as they're concerned somebody
told me about them I I knew that the
river had lots of fish and that the
place is beautiful and that it doesn't
get cold and that's why I went there
question from Laura would you call them
short-term thinkers and here were these
long-term thinkers they would be
short-term thinkers and and for
long-term thinkers the value of that is
to is to is to not devalue our immediate
experience to think about the future to
plan for tomorrow and for many
tomorrow's in advance but to learn to be
satisfied with the day as it is you know
one of the Bible verses that I thought
the pita high exemplified better than
any other is sufficient to the day is
the evil thereof take care of today and
and tomorrow will take care of itself
but it grows out of a confidence of
their ability to take care of themselves
that they don't have to worry about
tomorrow because they're confident they
show themselves that each day they're
able to take care of their needs and and
that is a is a solid way to think about
the future not out of fear but out of
confidence of being able to take care of
your daily needs so in their presence
you went from a faith based approach to
things to an evidence based it sounds
like to some degree that's true I mean I
think there are a lot of linguists that
would say that I'm still faith-based in
my linguistics but I think I've gone to
a more evidence-based approach a
question from Carolyn will make it the
last one do you talk to the women as
well as the man and as a man were the
women treating you speaking with you
sort of as a man or just as this weird
alien being a speaking dog or something
and there's a the question involves what
are the general relationships and you
have a sense of there's a recursive
question how your presence there had
effect on their culture or language well
clearly my presence there affects them
because it just as they show me other
ways of being I show them other ways of
being and so they see the things that I
do and and one of they were talking once
how did Dan learn our language so fast
nobody else has ever learned our
language and they said he just sits on
his butt all day and looks at paper and
that's the way you learn languages
but it made them think for the first
time about how you could learn another
language and so they started asking me
how to say things in English and
Portuguese and so you know what is that
called
Meza and then they said yeah but that's
ugly so we don't want to talk to it
sounds like
their culture is not going to be thrown
far off track by the likes of you there
are very resilient culture they I I
would say that over the last thirty
years my effect on them has been minimal
and their effect on me has been maximal
and it's finished with the gender thing
cos and this is of interest to all of us
who've been you know fighting hard to
get the genders equal and communicating
and equal pay and the rest of it here's
a situation where the genders have
almost different worlds to some extent
different language to some extent and
you're coming in were you a man speaking
into the women do you speak to the women
how are you treated in that well ears
before the women would say a word to me
because they first don't talk to
outsiders and second they don't but
after a few years when I could speak the
language pretty well I started telling
jokes around the women and they would
try not to laugh but they would start
laughing and then they just now they
talk to me normally and and so they talk
to me like they would any PETA ha man so
they do talk it's they do have spheres
of labor and and and specialty but the
women and men get along very well and
it's sometimes a man will stay home with
the children while the woman goes out
fishing and and he might stay home while
she goes to look for Brazil nuts so so
they and they take I don't notice a
great difference in the sense of status
between men and women in the society
well I've heard it said that in most
tribal groups are the women of the
botanists and the men of the zoologists
and that the case here yeah I would say
that the men are the ones that tell the
stories about the big one that got away
and the women are the ones that bring
the
food in period on thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]